Speaker 1: All right. A few other unhinged
reactions to cocaine found at the White House,
of course, in an area accessible to tour groups,
people from the public who come through. Here is
Republican Congressman Darrell Issa appearing
on Fox News. And he is directly bringing up the
Hunter Biden thing. He's straight up says,
listen, Hunter Biden, that's someone with
a history of drug addiction. They find cocaine
there. I don't know. I don't know. Here he is,
by the way, there's no evidence that this has
anything to do with Hunter Biden. It's actually
quite stupid to think it does. Let's listen.
Speaker 2: Huge difference when in fact, all
the president and then before that vice president
had to do was make it appear as though he was
behind his son. He has done that before. He did it
yesterday. He continues to have a somebody with a
history of drug addiction in the White House. And
it is not a small problem that we find cocaine
after Hunter Biden has been in the White House
and people roll their eyes and say, you know,
we never had this before. How what's changed?
Speaker 1: Yeah, right. Interestingly,
we didn't have it under Obama. We didn't have
it under George W Bush that that we knew about.
But Darrell Issa is being so irresponsible
here. Now, obviously, this is another one
of these completely ridiculous narratives
that accomplishes nothing as Republicans
continue to offer absolutely nothing by way of
policy to the American people that shouldn't
be ignored. Specifics aside, just the fact
that this is what they're talking about.
I just to do it justice. I'm not finding
any information that Hunter Biden is is
using cocaine at this point in time. The cocaine
was found were visitors leave their belongings.
So there's really no particular reason to
say Hunter Biden has anything to do with this
whatsoever. And at some point, you would think let
me apply a little bit of logic here. If Biden's
son were using cocaine and if he were using it at
the White House, these are all claims for which
we have no evidence. If all of those things were
true, why would he be doing it in the area where
visitors leave their belongings? In fact, he would
almost certainly not be there. The fact that this
is where it was found is essentially a guarantee.
This has nothing to do with Hunter Biden. But you
know that they don't that they didn't do their
health care plan, they didn't build the wall, they
didn't solve the Israeli-Palestinian conflict.
They didn't do any of those things. So what
they've got is Biden's son is in the White House
and he's snorting lines of coke while he is there.